he said
you've turned to the dark side
that you
killed younglings
now what's important to remember is that
anakin
is an adolescent the most recent studies
show that adolescence ends maybe in the
mid-20s so some of his behavior might be
developmentally appropriate granted
killing younglings is never acceptable
that is not normal behavior hey gq i'm
dr eric bender and this is the breakdown
[Music]
american psycho
anti-aging eye bomb followed by final
moisturizing protective lotion
there is an idea of a patrick bateman
patrick's routine at first
it seems like something you might see in
gq a 20-step process to look your best
for the day
what we actually see more of here though
is his narcissism the way he's
describing it i'm gonna do this and i'm
gonna use this there's that
preoccupation with beauty that he's
gonna look a certain way
what i find very interesting about him
is that he knows what he is and from dr
martin's interactions with jeffrey
dahmer and dennis nielsen we know that
psychopaths are aware that they function
differently than other people he's
saying i have this mask and this mask
you see and that doesn't tell you
anything about me i'm holding my cold
stare behind or my coldness inside
that is very true you get more into
philosophical arguments here about what
do we see on the outside do we really
know what somebody thinks what they do
we really don't you only can go by what
you see and what someone tells you so
there is a version of a patrick bateman
there's a mask it's very symbolic here
he peels off this mask he knows there's
things behind this mask it's almost like
there's two masks he creates a mask for
everybody to see he can peel off the
mask himself no one else can of what's
behind all that his own psychopath
inside he peels the mask off and reveals
that the mask he peels off right here
he's revealing just an outer shell to
everybody else and though i can hide my
cold gaze and you can shake my hand and
feel flesh gripping yours and maybe you
can even sense our lifestyles are
probably comparable
i simply am not
there
many of patrick's escapades say we say
in the movie are around narcissistic
injury the idea that he's perceived
someone telling him he's done something
wrong or that someone has scolded him in
some way or hurt his ego how he feels
about himself that drives a lot of his
behavior and that actually falls more in
line with the narcissist and more in
line with the psychopath
star wars episode 3 revenge of the sith
i am becoming more powerful than any
jedi has ever dreamed of and i'm doing
it for you to protect you
come away with me
so here you see anakin skywalker and
he's showing traits of a personality
disorder a personality disorder refers
to how someone interacts with the world
around them if it's vastly different
from the cultural norm it could be a
personality disorder meaning that person
experiences life and interactions with
other people and relationships very
differently than the norm these could be
elements of
psychopathy
psychopathy
is a personality construct it's the idea
that certain personality traits combined
with behavior create a psychopath what a
psychopath is or what psychopathy
represents is someone who is callous
uncaring does not
feel emotion for other people
but just uses people as pawns to gain
what they want that can sometimes
combine with narcissism or traits of
narcissism and that callousness and
uncaring can combine and you can see
that someone just goes ahead and does
whatever they want so that question is
here is anakin a psychopath it's
important to note that people with
narcissistic traits and narcissistic
personality disorder people with
borderline personality disorder other
personality disorder traits are not
psychopaths it's not necessarily that
someone has a borderline personality
disorder therefore they are violent it's
very important to note that mental
illness is
very rarely associated with violence the
traits of narcissism and borderline
personality disorder and histrionic
personality disorder have been
talked about in terms of psychopathy and
how when those traits pair with the
callousness and the uncaring and the
unemotional side that someone can have
that's when things become very dangerous
it's very important to note that people
with mental illness are not inherently
dangerous
no
you're with him
you brought him here to kill me
[Music]
so we're seeing traits of borderline
personality disorder the term borderline
actually refers to the idea of walking
on the border between psychotic or
there's a break from reality and
neurotic where someone's really trying
to manage the chronic distress and
anxiety that they feel someone with
borderline personality disorder or
traits of it might show chronic feelings
of emptiness they might have an identity
disturbance not feeling like there's a
stable sense of self here he's was he a
jedi was he a sith he's he's questioning
that now he seems to be more towards the
sith world someone with borderline
personality disorder also makes frantic
efforts to avoid any abandonment whether
it's real or perceived here he's
perceiving padme not wanting to do this
as abandonment and he's frantically
trying to kill her he's also going to go
up against obi-wan kenobi as another way
to avoid this abandonment that's his
response people with borderline traits
can also show impulsivity or intense
anger that's inappropriate that could
mean constantly being angry or almost
having tantrums
we see that here in anakin now what's
important to remember is that anakin
is an adolescent the most recent studies
show that adolescence ends maybe in the
mid-20s the brain really doesn't develop
fully until the mid-20s recent research
is showing so some of his behavior might
be developmentally appropriate as he's
actually coming into his teen years and
becoming a young adult granted killing
younglings is never acceptable that is
not normal behavior so that raises a red
flag in my head but
this has to be considered his age as a
child psychiatrist that's something i'm
considering too i'm also wondering here
about his background has he had
difficulty attaching to people so you
think about how he was pulled away from
his mother his mother died he has a fear
of padme dying like his mother died
so that was an issue and his mother was
also sold into slavery he didn't grow up
in the greatest environment love won't
save you padme
only my new powers can do that
at what cost
you're a good person don't do this
i won't lose you the way i lost my
mother the question of psychopathy i
come back in my mind to episode six in
return of the jedi the very end where
darth vader heaves the emperor into the
towers and into the electrical storm
that he falls and plummets to his death
in in that sense
anakin is showing that he really does
care for his
family his son for luke
it's not about him at that point
it's really about his child and that is
unusual for a psychopath to have that
level of love recent research shows that
psychopaths do actually feel emotion but
it's typically when it comes to them
achieving the goal that they want to
achieve so the level of love that darth
vader shows for luke in return of the
jedi really makes me think he's not a
psychopath you also have to consider the
developmental age of anakin at this time
i can't say for sure as a forensic
psychiatrist that this person meets
criteria on the psychopathy checklist
which is a list of personality traits
and behaviors that suggest someone is a
psychopath i can't say that for sure
here because there's still the
development of the young person
however there are a lot of clues that
he's on that way or on a path to
becoming a psychopath later
there is
that choice anakin or darth vader makes
to save his son
there is some choice now maybe there was
something that darth vader picked up on
in that scene i think we're led to
believe that there was a big change of
heart
somewhat that's hollywoodized but
there is this love that comes through
and i think that's what makes it clear
that he's not a psychopath in
psychopathy the studies show that you
can decrease behavior you can use
medication sometimes even to decrease
impulsivity but you wouldn't necessarily
teach someone to love more we have the
benefit now of knowing in episode six
something changes so i can say that
darth vader is not a psychopath looking
at the emperor would be a bit different
silence of the lambs
have a girl
you're so close to the way you're gonna
catch him do you realize that
no tell me why
after your father's murder you are
orphaned what happened next
dr lecter is in fact a psychopath he's
someone who doesn't really care about
people you can tell already even in the
way he interacts with clarice there is
this back and forth but it's really for
his benefit he says it'll be very
interesting to learn about your
upbringing and then he asks her about
these very traumatic times in her life
he wants that for his own personal
gratification quit pro
billy is not a real transsexual
but he thinks he is he tries to be he's
tried to be a lot of things i expect
clarice comes back to him and says quid
pro quo so i'll give you something you
give me something this for that
she's also playing on his narcissism
she's calling him doctor she never calls
him hannibal she calls him doctor all
the time playing up to that
narcissistic traits in a psychopath
often reflect a demand for a certain
respect or certain
praise that's what goes on here we see
that in their exchange
and you said that i was very close to
the way we would catch him what did you
mean doctor
there are three major centers for
transsexual surgery johns hopkins
university of minnesota and columbus
medical center
i wouldn't be surprised if billy had
applied for sex reassignment at one or
all of them and been rejected some
people would argue that dr lecter is not
a psychopath some people argue that
maybe he shows some kindness towards
clarisse in his own distinct way
psychopaths don't have to feel
absolutely nothing there's a study that
looked at psychopaths and whether they
could feel regret and that study showed
that psychopaths had regret
for things they did that caused them to
not win as much money in this exercise
in the study or to lose a lot of money
what was unique about the people who
scored high on the psychopathy checklist
was that they didn't use that regret to
make future decisions it wasn't that
they lost something or didn't gain
enough so therefore they should think
differently in the future it was about
regretting that moment
the retrospective regret looking back
they couldn't use that information to
look forward or prospectively so the
idea is that psychopaths can in fact
feel some regret or have some feeling
but it's really about them and their
goal it's not necessarily outside a
psychopath could care for a person or a
family member but again only to that end
of wanting to have that family or
wanting to have that person in their
life for a certain achievement or goal
there was a psychologist who worked with
the btk killer and that person even said
in multiple letters to her
that he really did understand that his
crimes affected his family and he asked
that his family be left out of any type
of research she was doing as she
communicated with him so i think in this
case
dr lecter is a psychopath even if he
feels something because we've seen from
research psychopaths can in fact feel
things quick pro quo
what's interesting about the camera
angle here is you see the reflection of
dr lecter in the glass where clarisse is
looking at him first what this scene
does is it draws you into the world of
dr elector you're fascinated and that's
true of psychopaths they can be very
charming and they can be really
interested in
you so it seems but it's really only to
their end in a psychopath you never know
what you're gonna get they're
pathologically lying so you don't know
who it is that you see you often see a
reflection of somebody but who is it and
what's behind that
the question of whether clary starling
or an fbi agent would talk to a
psychopath or a serial killer himself in
order to find out more about a case
it might be hollywood plot driving but
at the same time it is possible because
in trying to look for offenders
a forensic psychiatrist for instance
who's not an fbi agent
would look at all the records possible
there might be multiple interviews of
people dr lecter has intimate knowledge
of billy
here so the fbi will in fact use what
sources they can to understand and try
to solve the case particularly when
there are active murders going on
you
you sound apologetic like you're
embarrassed to be a good girl and you
murmur your first word to me
hello
we come to find out that this character
is a serial killer
just because his serial killer doesn't
mean that he can't have other obsessions
or other mental health issues in this
case it's it's not a mental health issue
like depression or anxiety
although serial killers can't have those
things
here this makes me think of stalking do
you work here
guilty
can i help you find something paula fox
it's a good choice
i feel weirdly validated there are
different types of stalking you can have
rejected stalking which is when
someone's been rejected in some way
there's a divorce they've been
terminated from work and therefore they
start to stalk somebody there can also
be predatory stalking where you're
stalking someone with the idea of spying
on them to eventually assault them in
some way
you can also have
erotomanic stalking which the idea that
you've realized this person is meant to
be with you and you think that they're
in love with you and you're in love with
them you can also have the incompetent
suitor type of stalking where someone is
fixated on a person and believes that
they're going to be involved in this
person's life and that person's going to
be their lover but that person's not
even available there there's someone
married or someone who's involved in
something else you can also have what's
called the resentful stalker where
someone is stalking someone or going
after them in a way just to derive
pleasure from distressing them or trying
to get them upset
in this case i wonder
because we're privy to his thoughts and
know that he's stalking this woman in
some way is it errato manic is he
thinking that there's a love
relationship here between the two of
them
or is it predatory is he planning to
attack her in some way is he planning to
do something to her given that he's a
serial killer we don't know but it's
possible that a serial killer could have
a relationship just because you're a
serial killer doesn't mean you wouldn't
have a relationship with other people in
fact some serial killers have these
secret lives they're married they have
kids but on the side at night when no
one knows they go out and they hunt for
victims
are you not wearing a bra
and you want me to notice
if this was a movie
i'd grab you and we'd go at it write in
the stacks
have you read her fiction
a psychopath might want a relationship
with somebody but typically they're
getting something out of it it's about
them it's not going to be about
providing for that other person it's
going to be about what that person does
for them
maybe they want to be a father and maybe
they're going to try to be with somebody
who wants to have children maybe they
want to have sex but it really is about
what that person wants
blue velvet
mommy
[Music]
we see the use of substances actually
he's huffing on gas some kind of
substance that's clearly making him high
when someone is high we do see behaviors
that can vacillate between
a very happy mood a very sad mood anger
it can all come out at one time or or in
this what's called labile mix of things
label going back and forth so he's one
minute almost sobbing for his mommy and
another minute he's very angry
and he's talking about in a very angry
way what he's gonna do he could be a
sexual sadist as well meaning that he's
deriving pleasure from the humiliation
and the suffering and the pain
of his victim in this case he punches
her tells her not to look at him he's
humiliating her he's hurting her he
seems to be getting off on this he's
also sold this woman's husband and child
into slavery so there really does seem
to be some kind of pleasure he gets out
of hurting other people
he doesn't care about other people he
cares about himself so he's clearly a
psychopath in this case
[Music]
psychopaths don't have to have a
component of sexual action or sexual
behavior in their acts we think of
serial killers and often there is a
sexual motivation there not necessarily
though sometimes it's just about the
killing it's not about sex it's not
about sexual pleasure that really brings
in that element of sexual sadism when it
becomes more about sexual arousal you
can have psychopaths who are motivated
by other things whether it's killing
whether it's financial grief or just
hurting people toying with people
doesn't have to be a sexual motivation
misery
well it's brilliantly written but then
everything you write is brilliant
pretty rough suffering
the swearing paul
annie might be the original toxic
superfan here the original troll instead
of having an online
platform she actually has the author
here in front of her
she gets quite upset with what he's
written the profanity and spills soup
all over the place as she gets so worked
up over it
in the bank do i tell mrs bollinger oh
here's one big bastard of a check give
me some of your christine money
there look there see what you made me do
when i think of annie i think of the
stalking behavior
and the particular type of stalking
behavior called that of an incompetent
suitor someone who despite having poor
social skills or potentially even some
social skills
has a fixation on someone and feels like
that person is meant for them and that
person has raised their interest in love
that person often is in a relationship
or not available and clearly that's the
case here annie's not going to marry
this author but she is treating him in
some
stalking type of way
we're starting to see an escalation here
where she's developing an attachment to
him it's been said that annie has
borderline personality disorder or
traits of that
people with borderline personality
traits can show a frantic
attempt to avoid abandonment by someone
in some ways she might be so frantic
here that she's going to correct him and
give him lessons on how to write so that
he will even stay there
sometimes i get so worked up
can you ever forgive me
might be that in her mind she's planning
out a way to keep him there we know
later she does horrific things to keep
him there
so that could be a trait of borderline
personality disorder people with
borderline personality traits often have
relationships that
vacillate between all good or idealized
and all bad or totally devalued
and that's can be called splitting she's
doing that here he's the greatest author
and then he's the worst author because
he uses profanity in a way that's not
realistic but then she loves him again
so she's back and forth on that the idea
that she might have bipolar disorder you
look for specific criteria for bipolar
disorder people often colloquially use
the word bipolar to mean hot and cold or
switching moods back and forth it's very
different when it comes to psychiatry a
bipolar disorder means that someone has
had a manic episode meaning that for
five to seven days they've had an
increased amount of energy to the point
that they're potentially grandiose
they're thinking that they're going to
accomplish and do things write the next
great novel change the course of
humanity play god know god
they might feel like their thoughts are
going all over the place and racing
they're not sleeping because of an
increased energy they might not need any
sleep for this five to seven day period
they're on top of the world in addition
they might be doing things that are a
change from baseline they might be
gambling or having sex with multiple
people doing
things that
are not necessarily safe or good for
them
we don't see this necessarily as a
change from her baseline so i can't say
that she has a bipolar disorder
[Music]
i love you paul
[Music]
your mind
there's still that justification with
annie of why she's doing what she does
to paul
the question of how can she go this far
she's got some justification in her mind
and she does seem to be very
psychopathic in what she does here
she's justifying it though
because she loves him she's saying all
of this now
that doesn't mean she's not psychopathic
because she's justifying it but the fact
that she has to
find some way to justify it to me that
might be more on the anti-social
spectrum as opposed to a psychopath
however if she didn't care about anybody
at all if this were beyond just him then
i would think okay maybe there's more of
a psychopathic trait here it's a
fixation on him so is there something
particularly obsessive about him is
there a fixation is there some kind of
delusion that this person is meant for
her that could be a psychotic delusion
most stalkers actually don't have
psychotic delusions some do though
thanks so much for watching these clips
with me stay tuned for part two